I'm here with Mark Nguyen.
He's a Course Manager here at Udacity.
So, Mark, why should a student
post to the Udacity forums?
>> That's a very excellent question.
Why should you not-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Want to post to the forums.
There's a couple of things of
why should you use the forums.
Number one is the forums are there, they
most likely have your answer already.
So if you're working on a project,
you're working through the course, and
if you find out that you
have a question, and
if you're stuck on something, most
likely there is already an answer there.
Most likely, a fellow student
has already asked that question.
And then you could just simply go
to the forum, search for it, and
then find your answer there.
The second thing of why you should use
the forum is to also practice your
communication skills on the forum,
and specifically,
how you should communicate
your problem and
how you should also conduct
yourself on the forum.
Because we've noticed that
the questions that are being posted,
the ones that get answered
frequently and the fastest,
are the ones that give everyone else the
entire context, the entire information.
So, when you're posting on the forums,
I really would highly recommend you to
really start thinking about how you
should phrase and frame your question.
And how you should give everyone
the entire context of your situation.
Here's my problem, here's what
I'm doing, here's what I've done.
Here's some snippets of my code,
if you have any code,
if you are working on a that has
coda in it, but basically give
everyone the entire context and
let everyone know what you know.
So, that could help you prevent
a lot of back and forth stuff and
help you go ahead and communicate in
a very succinct and efficient manner.
The forums really give
you a good area for
you to practice these
communication skills.
Third, and one I wanted to let you know
about is go ahead and help other people.
And if you teach the subject yourself,
you will actually have a deeper
knowledge of the material yourself.
So in addition to helping people,
in addition to communicating and
finding answers,
the forums serve as a rich resource for
you to network and help other people.
And then this will really help you gain,
understand the knowledge
on a deeper level.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And as well as build your
reputation on the forums.
Which goes to my fourth reason why you
should use forums is about networking.
It's all about networking.
We have a huge array of people
from all across the world,
from all walks of life and
they're all in it together,
and you somehow manage to build
a great reputation for yourself.
Guess what?
There will people who want to help you
out later on down the road, as well.
So, I highly recommend you to
really use the forums as your
tool to look up the information you
need, and also to help other people out.
>> Wow, thank you so much.
>> You're welcome.